ce qui nous anime c'est véritablement
redonner une place aux
victimes le procès c'est ce qui va
rendre
la dignité qu'ils ont perdu pendant ce
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
génocide moi je suis toujours FBR jour
j'attends toujours les jurés avec
impatience c'est toujours la même
question qui m
H est qu'ils vont comprendre cette
histoire France Info près de 30 ans
après la guerre civile au Rwanda le
génocide des TS entre 800000 et 1
million de morts un ancien gendarme
rwandais est jugé par la Cour d'assise
de Paris l'exmitaire aujourd'hui âgé de
66 ans est accusé de crime qu'il niit
[Musique]
formellement
je
m'appelleer je suis né au Rwanda il y a
très longtemps déjà j'habite à r aussi
depuis une petite quarantaine
[Musique]
d'années j'ai trois enfants j'ai un mari
Alain Gautier et notre histoire est
directement malheureusement liée au
[Musique]
génocide nous notre objectif c'est de
poursuivre en justice les personnes qui
sont soupçonnées d'avoir participé au
génocide perpétré contre les toutsis du
roi
et qui se trouve sur le territoire
français quand on s'est embarqué dans ce
combat pour la
justice on ne pensait pas que ça allait
n nous engager comme ça à ce
pointl depuis 94 nous n'avons pas passé
une journée sans parler du génocide sans
évoquer la vie des rescapés ou la
poursuite des génocidaires
[Applaudissements]
c'est que N faison
c'est de prendre notre bâton de péorin
d'aller au Rwanda interroger les vivants
les survivants qutillana interroger les
habitants des
lieux si on veut que ces génocidaires
présumé comparaissent devant la justice
on n pas d'autre choix en
[Musique]
fait
c'était un adjuge en chef àanza dans le
sud du du
Rwanda
ànanza on évoque la mort de 90000
personnes et biguma est mêlé à la
majorité de ses
[Musique]
crimes
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
94 a changé tout
94 c'est l'année zéro euh qui a rasé
tout qui a rasé nos vies on n'est pas
les seuls euh le génocide c'est un
ouragan qui dévaste tout absolument tout
et il n reste quasi
rien le génocide remonte très très loin
en
fait des historiens veulent nous faire
croire que le génocide a commencé
1994 ils le disent quand il viennent
témoigner dans les procès mais pour nous
il remonte beaucoup plus loin dans
histoire le génocide a été le produit
d'une politique raciste qui avait député
au Rwanda avec la
colisation avant la colonisation il y
avait les catégories sociales si vous
montez vous êtes considéré comme comme
un outil mais mais si vous êtes vraiment
quelqu'un qui reste le Comet de maroutel
vous êtes considéré
comme comme comme houtou tout le monde
pouvait monter mais comme aussi tout le
monde pouvait aussi
descendre on a AFF faaire là à un même
peuple donc à la fois les les TS et
lesou partagent les mêmes
valeurs les mêmes croyan parle la même
langue quand on avait beaucoup de vaches
on était é tout quand on était
cultivateur on était tout et on avait
très peu de vaches ça n'a jamais été des
races les Européens considéz que dans
chaque groupe des gens il y a ceux qui
sont supérieurs et
inférieur il va toujours se trouver des
des scientifiques qui vont aller mesurer
qui les crân qui les nez qui les
couleurs des yeux qui les cheveux et
cetera
il transforme en quelque sorte des
catégories sociales en catégories
racial cette pensée scientifique des
Européens va permet de justifier
l'emprise des toutsis de cette minorité
sur les utou c'est de par leur race
différente que les TS ont le droit en
quelque sorte de dominer la
massoutou les batous la race dominante
ce peuple de pasteur s'adonne
exclusivement à l'élevage et professe
pour tout autre travail un mépris absolu
les hommes se distinguent par leur haute
stature la finesse des attaches et leur
fi démarche les baoutou qui représente
90 % de la population sont des paysans
bantou à l'âme lourde et passive
ignorant tout souci du
lendemain les Allemands mais surtout les
Belges avaient besoin gr sur lesquel il
s'appuyent pour diriger le pays alors
ils se sont appuyés sur les ous et
naturellement ils vont créer un
ressentiment de la part d'utou qui
jusqu'àors avait un certain rôle et
jusqu'alors occuper un certain nombre de
fonctions relativement
importante à partir des années
1950 lesoutis commence à manifester les
véités d'indépendance au moment de la
décolonisation
il y a au sein de de l'élite
touts il y a des idées d'indépendance
d'indépendantiste et naturellement ça
fait peur au colonisateurs belges et
donc ce qu'ils vont faire c'est qu'ils
vont renverser à 180 degrés leur
politique où désormais ce seront plutôt
les autours qui vont être
favorisés et donc ils vont favoriser
cette fois-ci une prise de pouvoir tout
simplement par un parti extrémiste
tout
[Musique]
et c'est à ce moment qu'on a commencé à
considérer les T comme des citoyens de
seconde
zone à chaque fois qu'il y avait des
problèmes ils étaient considérés comme
des beaux cissaires et
exminés on peut parler à peu près à la
fois de milliers de morts et puis
d'uneun émigration extrêmement
importante d'une grande partie de la
population
touts on chass les de chez eux on Piait
on brûlait euh voilà si tu pars pas tu
es tué tout
[Musique]
simplement en
1990 les enfants expulsés les les exilés
de 1959 ont grandi et donc ils ont un
désir de de revenir dans leur pays
d'origine
le fr patriotique Rwanda a été créé en
grande parti par les descendants des
réfugiés de 1959 et ils ont attaqué le
pays à par du 1er octobre
1990 il y a une sorte de panique qui
surgit au sein des gens qui dirigent le
Rwanda c'estàdire lesuto il y a à la
fois la peur du toutsile extérieur et
une grande méfiance une par
en ce qui concerne les tout de de
l'intérieur et donc lentement mais
sûrement on va développer un certain
nombre d'outils pour préparer finalement
la population tout à
l'irréparable et donc on va développer à
la fois des
milices on va faire des achats massifs
d'armes pour pouvoir les distribuer à la
population et puis la fameuse création
de radio
qu'on va qualifier non sans raison de
radio
machette
[Musique]
début de l'année 94 je pense que ma mère
commençait
à avoir envie de nous voir en
fait bon je vais au
Rwanda était à feu à son ptig Gali des
grenades pété par partout
euh il y avait des assassinats ciblé
j'ai des touttil donc ma mère m'a dit il
faut que tu repartes il faut que tu
partes parce que là ça va très très mal
j'ai courté mon séjour je suis rentrée
mais je savais que j'allais pas les
revoir ça c'est
sûr c'est
sûr
d'ailleurs tout ce que j'ai laissé ce
jour-là son
plus ben moi jeou j'ai sauvé ma
peau puis après le mois d'après c'était
ce qu'on
sait se raconte pas ça se
vit les circonstances de la mort des
présidents Rand et burund ne sont pas
clair hier soir l'avion qui les ramené
de Tanzanie s'est écrasé quelques
minutes avant son atterrissage à Kigali
Randa d'après certains témoins l'avion a
essuyé des tirs d'autres parle
d'explosion juste avant
[Musique]
l'atterrissage
le 6 avril donc 94 l'avion du président
abana est abattu donc le président meurt
et donc il y a une vacance de pouvoir et
c'est un prétexte qui va permettre aux
autoextrémistes de prendre le pouvoir et
tout simplement gérer la mise en œuvre
du
[Musique]
génocide
ang h
wa
m eh WAZ
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cous éit ici àanza il était enseignant
il a été joueur de foot ici il avait C
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
enfants il a été ramené avec sa famille
et
lui l'OIR dit que on lui aurait coupé la
tête et on aurait joué au foot avec sa
tête ici à l'intérieur même de ce stade
[Musique]
voilà ça demande déjà beaucoup d'énergie
pour poursuivre cette quête de
justice alors évidemment qu les
histoires familiales s' mè tomber sur sa
famille sur ses cousins ses amis ça fait
perdre
[Musique]
pied Raphaël était grand est
beau j'ai quelques photos
[Musique]
mais
ashiz
muzeim
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
im
ils sont bien gardés
heinou les
cercueil ah oui ou ou ou là
là si on peut trouver 38000 tout
pour ça qui sont été morts tué par
bigoua et ses
alliés
ici une fois le mois du mois j'arrive
ici toute la
famille
maman et
papa pensée
pour vous n'aviez pas de photo
disparu aussi ou c'est ça aussi le drame
le drame de
de on nous a on nous a volé toutes nos
photos aussi on nous a volé n souvenirs
c'està dire qu'en brûlant les maisons à
les pillant on nous a tout
pris ai parce que j'étais ENF oui nous
c'est pareil moi j'ai ma mère elle avait
tout elle avait toute sa petite caisse
je vois en bois il y avait toutes les
photos que mon frère envoyé d'Europe
avec les enfants les photos quand on
était petite moi j'ai pas de photos
quand je suis petit tout est parti dans
pH qu'on
pr c'est ce qui a permis d'identifier
certaines
victimes on a retrouvé la carte
d'identité dans les poches les
carnetsill
même les les Bigou même les
[Musique]
bigouis
ça c'est la carte
d'identité là ici je pense que c'est
marqué c'est barré et
tout à côté ça c'est la signature de ta
condamnation à
mort
c'est pour ça qu'on peut pas laisser
quand même des gens qui ont fait ça les
laisser vivre non plus
[Musique]
tranquille cette période de 3 mois de du
génocide on va vivre je dirais comme des
fantômes nous passons nos nuits au
téléphone euh on envoie des faxes on
envoie
des des des des appels au secours il y a
pas beaucoup de mots pour raconter ce
qu'on pouvait ressentir
euh cette culpabilité qui vous rongez
moi qui me ronger je venais de les
laisser je les vois encore cette image
où tout le monde me fait
le 8 avril je je suis dans mon
bureau au collège handarc à reins je
téléphone je téléphone à la paroisse où
je je sais que la maman de d'froosa
s'est
réfugiée et le père Blanchard m'annonce
que la maman de la frosa a été tuée le
matin militair sont
venus chasser tous les réfugiés de
l'église ils ont tiré dans le tas la
maman d'fosa fait partie des des
victimes j'ai la lourde charge en
rentrant le soir à la maison
d'annoncer la mort de de la
maman de la grand-mère des
enfants ma mère s'appelait Suzanna
con
[Musique]
Alain adore les
oiseaux moi tu vois depuis 94 j'ai unein
une phobie presque 94 les rapaces sans
sont donné à cœur joie il n'arrêtait pas
de manger les corps des
nres dans autre trauma sûrement tu
penses tout de suite à
ça tu ne penses pas à la beauté de
roiseau je ne vois pas un rapacee en
terme de poésie c'est c'est malheureux
hein un génocide ne réussit jamais
complètement hein puisqu'il y a toujours
des rescapés et ces rescapés sont
là pour pouvoir témoigner de ce qui
s'est passé
[Musique]
tout repose sur des témoignages dans le
cadre du génocide des
tout beaucoup de documents écrits ont
été détruits depuis 30 ans beaucoup de
témoins ne sont plus et si on ne récolte
pas ces témoignag on ne pourra plus
organiser des procès en France donc il y
a
urgence
[Musique]
C uneéion habité de par beaucoup de tout
il y a des où il n'y avait que des
d'ailleurs et où aujourd'hui
malheureusement reste personne
[Musique]
non qu'est-ce que c'est beau oh là là
mercionon
moi
significatif ça va ça semble ça semble
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bar
ah c'est très fort derrière tous les
gens
écoutent tout le monde écoute mais bon
c'est leur histoire
[Applaudissements]
auss comment veux-tu qu'on prenne pas
toutes ces ondes
[Musique]
là
c'est le plus
importantageés et ça c'est ce qu'il
faut
à la fin du génocide biguma s réfugié au
Congo il a d avoir magouilles pour qu'il
puisse prendre l'avion sans papier mais
en tout cas il s'est retrouvé en France
en fin de juin
1994 la France a mise en place ce qu'on
a appelé l'opération
turquise pour créer des zones de
sécurité la France a décidé de lancer
une opération humanitaire au Rwanda je
crois que le premier objectif est
atteint avec encore une fois tous ces
sourires qui fleurissent sur vos
visages mais la zone turquise n'a été
que une sorte de couloir pour faire fuir
une grande parté de de la population et
exfitrait les autorités qui venaient de
commettre le
[Musique]
génocide et donc l'opération Turquoise
va permettre à des centaines de génocid
routou donc des responsables des
génocides routou de quitter le
territoire rwandais et qui par la suite
iront pour certains en France pour
d'autres en Belgique ou encore au
Canada ici en France ils se sont refait
une virginité ce sont de bons parents ce
sont de bons voisins ce sont de bons
citoyens qui qui s'impliquent dans des
associations
humanitaires voire des bons
chrétiens vous imaginez nous avons nos
familles
décimées et vous voyez des ferl dans nos
pays ici les assassins de nos famille
mais mais c'est un scandale c'est pas
possible
elle importe qui s indignerait je
[Musique]
pense depuis plus de 20 ans nous avons
déposé plus d'une trentaine de plaintes
et jusqu'à maintenant malheureusement
seules C personnes ont été jugé et
[Musique]
condamné
la France c'est pratiquement le seul
pays aujourd'hui qui refuse toujours
d'extrader ces personnes là vers le
Rwanda où ils auraient déjà été jugés
d'où ce grand nombre de de dossiers qui
s'amcell sur le bureau des juges qui ne
sont pas suffisamment nombreux nous ne
cessons depuis 25 ans de dénoncer une
lenteur insupportable pour les pour les
victimes
en 2015 nous avons reçu une lettre
anonyme dénonçant biguma il travaillait
à l'université de Rennes comme
responsable de la sécurité donc
immédiatement nous nous avons nous nous
sommes emparés de ce
dossier
les rescapés c'est pas eux qui ont le
plus
vu c'està-dire que un rescapé soit il
sont caché dans un trou de souris soit
il était caché dans un plafond d'un
[Rires]
bienfaiteur mais par contre les tueurs
on a besoin de leur parole de leur
témoignage parce que c'est eux qui
savent mais vous savez entrer dans une
prison c'est pas si facile que ça quand
on sait qu'il
habite il accepte de
parler de parler du génocide
ici
[Musique]
vous pas
au détour d'une phrase vous allez déjà
comprendre des
choses
[Musique]
okgur professionnel il a eu la perpète
mais en fait la seule chose qu'il sait
c'est m'a attiré sur ce truc il a tué il
a tué un bœuf il a tué le taureau des
vaches de non j'avais pas envie de
traduire parce que en fait j'en peux
plus oh là là moi j'étais dans un état
bah il faut dire que il n' dégagé que
des ZES négatives tu pouvais pas être
bien là si c'est ça mais j'avais j'avais
envie de lui dire tais-toi tais-toi mais
continue
[Musique]
à chaque fois c'est des très jolis
endroits c'est incroyable oui c'est le
décalage entre le macabre et la beauté
et toujours
saisissant et quel que soit l'endroit
même nous on s'habitue pas on croit
qu'on pourrait s'habituer mais on
s'habitue pas
malheureusement je sais pas s'il faut
s'habituer
d'ailleurs allez
ça a été aussi un grand lieu de
résistance de la part des TS quand les T
se réfugia en haut des collines il se
défendait à coup de Pierre si bien que
il a fallu parfois plusieurs attaques
soit des miliciens soit des gendarmes
pour venir à bout de leur
résistance
[Musique]
kusang
hanj
Go je m'appelle
Tarcis je suis maître en
karaté j'ai commencé le karaté en
78 et maintenant je suis Cintu noir 7e
d comme la majorité me connaissait comme
un karaté 4 quand je donnais les ordres
accepté j'ai expliqué aux gens que ceux
qui viennent vous tue ils ont deux bras
ils ont deux jambes ils ont deux yeux
ils ont le sang rouge comme nous faut
pas qu'ils ai peur parce que il faut
qu'ils engagent le
combat en utilisant les pierres on peut
lancer à quelqu'un qui a un fusi si nous
rançons ensemble les Pierr contre lui tu
parviens à
lutter on a résister contre eux pendant
au moins 2
semaines et après il y avait une petite
route qu'on a suivi vers le Burundi il y
avait beaucoup de barrièr qui fallit
franchir c'était pas
facile parce que chaque barrière on
faisait un
[Musique]
combat nous avons perdu beaucoup de
gens avant on avait fait un petit
recensement on était
3480 ce qui ont
pu franchir la la rivière vers le
Bundi juste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
118 j'avais une grande famille y compris
ma femme et mon enfant tout a été
perdu
B il va être face à la justice il va
être face au parti civil que nous sommes
et surtout il va être face aux
victimes c'est important pour le Rwanda
pour l'écriture de cette histoire là des
lieux et cette histoire du génocide et
en cela on peut se dire voilà à quoi ça
sert aussi notre
[Applaudissements]
travail salut c ah ben on est comme vous
on est comme vous on
attend vous voyez quoi bon cro des dois
oui oui ouais quand même on commence à
avoir un nœud dans le ventre moi ça
commence tout doucement
s'inaller
stresse stresse du
verdict je m'habitue toujours
oui
ou oui
confiance
[Musique]
moi j'ai j'étais dans un stress tu as
jamais vu
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pense à cet instant même à toutes les
victimes biguma et ses pères ont infligé
la perpétuité en fait les les rescapé
vivent une ont été condamnés à
perpétuité depuis presque 30 ans donc
c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre je vais pouvoir leur dire que
ils ne sont pas venus dire des choses
pour
rien ils sont venus le dire ici à
Paris dans cette cour d'assise et et
leur souffrance a été entendue et
[Musique]
merci c'est la justice
remerci
je dis que le génocide toujours ça
aurait pu être un événement qui aurait
pu faire exploser aussi notre couple
mais je crois que c'est un peu ce qui
nous ce qui nous a soudé encore
davantage parce qu'on avait ce combat à
mener je pense qu'on ce combat qu'on ne
peut plus abandonner et qu'on mènera
jusqu'à la fin de nos
jours on aura au moins la satisfaction
d'avoir fait peut-être quelque chose de
de bon d'important dans notre dans notre
existence da frosa dit souvent
effectivement on
est des gens peu importants mais qui
avant été entraînés dans des événements
excessivement importants
euh bon voilà c'est notre
[Musique]
histoire